in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and with me the
studio is Hannah fed she's a
psychologist by training in to stress
management coach he offers courses on
self-management and how to avoid burnout
hi great to have you on the show thank
you very much no how do I tell that I'm
stressed out our body is very clever it
shows us in different ways that we have
stressed we can feel it in by having
pain in the back or neck for example
normally we get problems in the bowel or
stomach we have difficulties to take our
mind off for example a particular
problem and ponder around the we start
to make more mistakes as the
concentration gets worse and a very
typical sinus having difficulties with
the sleep by either not falling asleep
easily or waking up after about three
hours so that's very typical signs so
there are lot of buddies signs aren't
there yeah this is not as the feeling to
be stressed but the body rates to it how
can I tell that is this a normal kind of
stress on the daily routine or that it's
burnout yeah well as long as we are able
to regenerate after acute situations of
stress we shouldn't worry too much but
when the step stress gets chronic um we
might have difficulties and major
difficulties because that can lead to a
severe physical and mental exhaustion
and that's what we call Bernard that can
lead to the situation that the person is
not able to handle on his or her day
anymore to get up in the morning go to
the bakery and get through the day and
the this is due to psychological crisis
normally and the core of this crisis is
on that the person experienced a failing
in the personal very important values
and goals of life
they start normally then I'm start
self-doubting um and losing the purpose
in life so why do people cope
differently with different kinds of
stress well the research currently is
trying to find reasons for that in the
genetics on what we definitely know is
that the the first about seven years of
one's life are very crucial to that so
when we experience or if we experienced
traumatic situations they can make us
more susceptible to its stress later on
in our life so basically we are not all
on the same concerning the stress
resistance but everyone can improve his
or home stress resistance on by training
this is hell do you have it a special
trip for stress reduction well there's
not one special tip but there's a whole
lot of things to you think about what I
generally find very important is to
check from time to time whether we are
happy in our life in general whether we
have the feeling to have a purpose in
life and live the goals and the the
values that are important for us and
once that is set um or has to be changed
and then may need to take action from
way to wait in order to make sure that
what's working the body should be cared
for so we need I'm diet on a healthy
diet we need arm lots we need sports we
need enough sleep we need on breaks for
relaxation to keep the body healthy so
that's a few major things so how do we
find my personal coping strategy which
fits me most yeah well what I just said
is some pretty important for everyone in
general but the actual on strategy might
look very different when we look closer
at the actual reason for why a person is
stressed so for example one person might
be stressed because the person has
difficulties to withdraw and tell the
people are sorry I can't help you at the
moment because the person always wants
to help me other people and another
person might have difficulties because
he wants
do everything on his own and would
actually need to accept help from other
people to find personal balance so in
yeah yeah it could you show us a single
exercise which I could fit into my daily
routine to reduce my stress level yeah
there are several relaxation techniques
and one for example is the progressive
muscle relaxation that can easily be
fitted into um everyday life and what
you basically do is you on you put
pressure and tension in your fist and
your lower arm and you focus on this
part and concentrate on it for about
seven eight seconds and then after seven
seconds you just let go and you stay
with your attention there and you focus
on what is developing now and then you
do this first and the next one will be
on you take your arm like this then you
do the same with the muscles in the
upper arm again for seven and twenty
seconds let go and the third one would
be you can press your art your hand like
this and then again the same system to
press down on the press it down yeah 47
seconds and then you can focus on the
twenty-second afterwards and you do it
on the site on the other side and what
actually happens is that this reduces
the tension in our muscles and by
reducing this tension um the whole body
starts to get into a relaxation stage
and that's that can easily be done i
justjust do this with my hand and my
whole body can relax and this is easily
to fit into my daily imagine you can go
through the whole body as well there's
not only the hands and arms but you
could do that as a start right when we
need to seek professional help um well
if you if you realize that the the
symptoms get stronger you suffer from
that and you don't find your own way out
um then it's important to seek
assistance um to see you doctor to make
sure that there's no other organic
reasons um that can lead to this some
stress level and then it also can be
very important to find psychological
help to find the actual reason for why
you are stressed so what is the first
person to seek help and did she pee the
yeah yeah and then talk about talk about
your stay to the GP and then
from there you can continue great thanks
for having you on the show yeah I will
vary try to close my fist and get my
personal stress level reduced thank you
so much
you
you